the gimps have been at it again they
found there a new prime number at the
largest prime number that's been found
to date the gimps of course a great
internet Mersenne prime search team
network of computers and people that
work on these computers that look for
large mess em primes is it's pretty big
number 2 to the power now I've got
remember this now fifty-seven million
eight hundred and eighty-five thousand
one hundred and sixty one minus one so
there fifty-seven million eight hundred
eighty-five thousand one one is a prime
number but this bad boy the whole thing
is also a prime number of course it's a
much bigger one and that is the largest
prime number ever to being found
it's the 48th Mersenne prime ever to
being found as well can you remind us
what immersed in prime is yeah so
essentially the base M prime you just
take two you take it to some power P and
this is a prime number minus one and
that's your mass M Prime it's pretty
interesting how they've gone about
finding this as well I mean they're I
mean there's various things about it I
mean for example that the way it's done
is they have this this gimps network and
have this you know there are a network
of shared computers and they use their
combined a computing power to basically
work out try and find these prime
numbers so it's quite an interesting
that this sort of collaboration going on
to find these things from my point of
view it's actually reminiscent of
something that they do at the LHC to
manage the data they they basically they
use a a network of computers around the
world to analyze that data so it's not
always academics that are finding these
things that anybody can get involved in
the project and and as you know there's
money on the table as well when it comes
to finding these things and Curtis
Cooper will win looks like three
thousand dollars for for finding this
number it's very shame for him because
this number actually has a well it has
this many digits as this many digits
long it is 17 million four hundred and
twenty five thousand and one hundred and
seventy digits long I think the reason
this is a little bit annoying for Curtis
Cooper is that it's not a hundred
million digits long
because if it been a hundred millions
digits long then he would have worn 150
thousand dollars because that's the
prize on offer if you can find one for
it that's actually that long it's worth
thinking about how big this number
actually is and we've talked about big
numbers in the past brady it is bigger
than a googol it's not as big as a
googolplex it's certainly not as big as
Graham's number you can easily think of
this number without your head collapsing
for a black hole there's no problem
there in fact actually it's it's it's
quite easy to think of you could even
memorize this number here we have the
number so this is the number written out
in full there's a quite a big file there
you go it's got a seventeen and a half
million digit this file is about 22 Meg
now apparently your brain can store
about 2.5 million gig of memory so
technically you could memorize this
number without having a problem and in
fact I'm going to be cocky here because
I actually can write this and I'm going
to write this number I've remembered
this number but I've remembered it in
base two okay so let me write it out in
there in base two I was quite impressed
that I remembered this so the first
number is 1 the second number it's also
1 and the next one's also one and the
next one is also 1 and I would carry on
writing one until I got all away the
last number which is also 1 and there
would be a grand total of 500 550 7
million 885 thousand one hundred and
sixty one of these ones and that is the
number written in base 2 so I can prove
that for you if you like oh okay
so so the reason that that's the that's
why it is in base 2 ok so so what is it
let's look at this number this let's
just call it P fan out rather than this
57 million because we can prove this in
in generality I can actually factorize
this expression and I can factorize this
expression as follow it's 2-1 ok that's
obviously 1 multiplied by 1 plus 2 plus
2 squared just all the way up to 2p
minus 1 ok so this is obviously 1 out
front
so what I'm left with is just Ollie
basically the essential units of air
base - with ones in front that's it so
that's the proof so it's obviously P of
these so in total so this is in our case
P is 57 million H 5161 and so this is
how you would write it out in base 2 in
base 10 which is what more people are
familiar with what's the first and last
digit so I'm gonna have to look this one
over well I think I know the first
actually it's five isn't it it's five
and the last one cannot can I look yeah
I've got a feeling the last ones well we
know it's going to be an odd-numbered
only so it's good one there you go of
course we have a new perfect number okay
from this and it's very easy to write
down what it is and the perfect number
that we have two to the fifty-seven
million eight hundred eighty-five
thousand one hundred and sixty x two to
the fifty-seven million eight hundred
and eighty five one hundred and sixty
one minus one that's our new perfect
number it's about 34 million digits long
yep that's our new perfect number we got
out of this so whew so it's all good fun
basically isn't it and I think there is
an important point to come from these
searches I mean they're not that they're
fun to look at it's nice that you know
it's interesting oh we found this new
this new this new big prime number
there's a lot of technology that goes
into sort of developing the software to
do these calculations because you know
basically you actually tried to
calculate all the divisors of this guy
you used all the numbers that are
smaller than it and try to you know see
if they were factors of that number you
know you did that you know just like
that
you know it sort of blindly you know
you'd find that you needed more than the
age of the universe to actually do that
calculator so there's sophisticated
techniques that work here and all this
game and all its developing this
computing power you know the particular
ways to multiply large numbers really
had you know sort of impact elsewhere
for example you know so it's the
spin-off technologies that are coming
from this sort of you know really
mathematicians playing games but you
know you should never knock
mathematicians playing games because
they can
you know the breads the crumbs that fall
off the table can have benefits
everybody else if you'd like to see even
more from this interview including a
rather strange discussion about my
family tray I've got an unlisted video
with all the offcuts and extra footage I
basically didn't put it as a listed
video because I didn't want to clog up
everyone's subscription boxes and if you
want to find out more about some of
these topics and you haven't watched our
back catalogue of videos I've also put
links to our films about Mersenne primes
perfect numbers googles and google
plexes grams number all that kind of
stuff check out the links under the
video or here on the screen